morgen ist es also soweit das nächste
treffen der bundesregierung und der
ministerpräsidenten der länder wie geht
es weiter im chor ohne lockdown sprechen
wir darüber mit professor gernot marx
der ist direktor der klinik für
operative intensivmedizin und
intermediate care an der uniklinik der
rwth aachen und präsident der deutschen
interdisziplinären vereinigung für
intensiv und notfallmedizin divi schönen
guten tag herr max guten morgen herr
bauer
er mag sie sind gegen eine verabredung
zu lockerungen am morgigen mittwoch
warum
ja es ist trotzdem hier schon so lange
es durchgehalten
dennoch wichtig dass wir die maßnahmen
die lockdown maßnahmen fortführen weil
wir die im quelle vor die
infektionswelle bringen müssen und diese
nächsten drei wochen bis anfang april
sind wirklich entscheidend dass wir eine
dritte welle deutlich reduzieren
beziehungsweise vielleicht sogar fast
ganz verhindern wenn wir ganz viel
impfen können deswegen sind wir als
intensivmediziner aus sicht der
intensivmedizin für eine beibehaltung
des lockt das heißt wenn ich sie richtig
verstanden habe in diesen drei wochen
hoffen sie darauf dass deutlich mehr
geimpft wird und damit würde man dann
die dritte welle sozusagen er überholen
sie keine sozusagen nicht richtig zum
tragen
ganz genau
es ist im prinzip haben wir dann einen
triathlon vor uns wir müssen diese das
virus weiter durch die lockeren
maßnahmen in der ausweitung der mutation
behindern
wir müssen möglichst viel impfen
möglichst hohe impfrate plus eben weiter
dann auch darauf achten dass sie diesen
reproduktions wert diesen er wird auf
jeden fall unter 1,2 hatten mit diesen
drei maßnahmen werden wir es schaffen an
der dritte welle vielleicht sogar zu
verhindern mindestens deutlich zu
reduzieren
was passiert denn wenn weiter so
schleppend geimpft wird wie bisher
bitte was passiert denn wenn weiter so
schleppend geimpft wird wie bisher dann
geht ja ihre rechnung nicht auf
ja aber die informationen die uns zur
verfügung stehen deutet darauf hin dass
wir doch jetzt viel mehr impfdosen jetzt
schon bekommen und noch mehr im april
und dazu auch noch neue impfstoffe zb
gehen wir davon aus dass johnson johnson
und vielleicht noch eine weitere
impfstoff bald zugelassen wird
von daher gehen wir davon aus dass wir
wirklich bald sehr sehr viel impfdosen
für die bevölkerung zur verfügung haben
werden herr professor max wenn sie sagen
noch mehr im april verstehe ich sie
richtig dass sie wirklich für einen
weiteren locker und bis ende april wären
nein das ist nicht nötig wir haben ja
letzte woche unser die wie
prognosemodell vorgestellt und es ist
tatsächlich so dass diese nächsten drei
wochen sehr entscheidend sind wenn es
wenn das dann gelingt dann kommt es hin
dass wir dann selbst im april noch mehr
impfen
diese dritte welle wirklich verhindern
können sie haben ihre simulation ständig
reduzieren können sie haben ihre
simulation von letzter woche schon
angesprochen da warnen sie vor 4000
cupid 19 patienten auf den
intensivstationen wenn jetzt gelockert
würde
der höchststand war am dritten januar
2021 also diesen jahres bei 5.745 also
nochmal etwa 40-50 fast über dem was sie
befürchten in deutschland gibt es über
30.000 intensivbetten das scheint mir
alles sehr weit weg von einer eskalation
also ich frage mich wo ist da die
überforderung der intensivstationen auf
den krankenhäusern in den krankenhäusern
wegen denen ja die politik diesen
lockdown auch aufrecht erhält
ja eine berechtigte frage
allerdings ist so wie wenn sie werden ja
so verschiedene prognosemodelle
angesetzt das kommt darauf an wie
schnell wir impfen wie hoch die inzidenz
der mutation ist und wann wir heben
lockern und 4000 war der eine werde das
ging ja weit über 10.000 patienten wenn
jetzt alles ganz in die schlechte licht
richtung läuft und von daher ist es eben
sehr wichtig dass wir diese
infektionsfälle möglichst nach hinten
bringen und eben deutlich reduzieren es
gibt nicht nur um 4.000 patienten
sondern um deutlich mehr als im pik der
zweiten welle also wir gehen im
schlimmsten fall wirklich von über
10.000 patienten
dieses worst case genaue glaube ich
würde aber nicht stattfinden weil ja die
politik das ganze während der ganzen
corona pandemie immer sehr
verantwortungsvoll sich auch diese
zahlen angeschaut hatten die prognosen
und entsprechend auch verantwortungsvoll
gehandelt haben aber ich verstehe sie
regt eine überforderung der
krankenhäuser der intensivstation in den
krankenhäusern die befürchten auch sie
nicht im schlimmsten fall ist das so und
vor allen dingen müssen wir natürlich
bedenken
wir haben jetzt schon ein japan dem
wiener hinter uns unsere teams sind
wirklich sehr erschöpft das war das
anstrengendste jahr für die
intensivmedizin seitdem es sie gibt in
deutschland nicht glaube auch weltweit
und unsere teams sind schon wirklich
sehr erschöpft physisch psychisch und
auch seelisch der virologe und die
menschen sind ja letztendlich keine
maschinen das verstehe ich absolute wir
noch mal auf 23 andere stimmen kommen
der virologe und epidemiologe professor
klaus stöhr der viele jahre für die
weltgesundheitsorganisation tätig war
der red davon ab nur auf die inzidenz
werte zu schauen
der virologe professor streek sagt
geschäfte können öffnen mit konzepten
die es ja schon gibt der spd
gesundheitspolitiker karl lauterbach der
schlägt im aktuellen spiegel vor alle
menschen in schulen und betrieben an
einem tag pro woche zu testen
an dem sie dann auch in geschäfte dürfen
noch mal die frage an sie sind öffnungen
mit konzepten nicht doch machbar
aus sicht der intensivmedizin haben wir
auch gesagt dass wir von der strategie
des incidents wert alleine abrücken und
vorgeschlagen haben dass wir mehr auf
den re produktionswert schauen es ist
glaube ich ganz wichtig dass dieser
reproduktions werten nicht über 1,2
steigt wie es im oktober letzten jahres
dann der fall war und dann ging es ins
exponentielle wachstum aber welche
maßnahmen erst die richtigen sind im
rahmen der strategie das ist
letztendlich nicht unsere entscheidung
als intensivmediziner das verstehe ich
hab ja sozusagen den perspektiv rahmen
gesetzt sie haben eine perspektive von
seiten der intensivmedizin gesetzt
vielen dank ihm professor gernot marx
präsident der deutschen
interdisziplinären vereinigung für
intensiv und notfallmedizin vielen dank
in der max hier bei uns bei phoenix im
tagesgespräch
serie 1